it has become a grim routine attacks and
explosions while the city sleeps
followed by disbelief and anxiety
survivors wondering how they escape the
ferocity of a missile love from afar on
their homes
marat can't contain his anger
europe sold us out americans
don't cut me out we asked them to close
the sky but they didn't why traitors to
protect their children i'm going to
appeal directly to the other
do you understand who i'm talking about
you son of a
i would tear you apart with my own hands
there are few people left in mikolaiv a
few weeks ago there were nearly half a
million those still here have to rely on
handouts as there's no more drinkable
water
with the economy at a standstill people
are selling whatever they own to pay his
utility bill he tells us
even though there are no buyers
the russians had actually reached this
point on the outskirts of mikolav in the
early stages of the war before being
pushed back but now with mariupol and
the herzone region effectively under
russian control there is concern that
they could be preparing for a counter
offensive
that might be why people are not
returning to the town of bashtanka yet
it was recaptured about a month ago
it just looks like every town village or
city the russians occupied
elena remembers the night it all started
her house was among the first hit
parachute bombs fell from the sky
leaving a huge crater
are the straps
and the parachutes canopy has now been
recycled
the ukrainian army says it's on the
offensive in the south
the moral of the enemy is low and they
are not advancing on the ground because
they can't break our lines the sanctions
are having an impact they can't produce
certain weapons anymore but one of the
russian advantages is their artillery
systems their range is longer than ours
and can hit us hard
russia also holds the upper hand when it
comes to attacks from the sky and each
night the people of mikolav wonder whose
turn will it be next
al jazeera nikolaev